الخرجه اكبر تظاهره للاحتفال باللباس
التقليدي التونسي تحيي الموروثه وتؤذن
بقدوم فصل الربيع
عشاقها بعضهم يرتدي ازياء معتقه يناهز
عمرها القرنه واخرى تورثها عبر اجيال او
اعدوها بانفسهم خصيصا لهذا الحدث
الجبه هذه عمرها قرن 100 سنه اخترت باش
نشارك بها احيال الموروث الاجداد مصنوعه
من الصوف مصبوغه بالحنه والرمان كيما
كانوا جدودي يصبغوا فيها
في الدم حاجه في الدم فهمت دونك سناي حبيت
الحقيقه ما حبيت حتى تحدي لبسني حبيت نلبس
وحدي اللبسه هذه كل من تصميمي انا وحدي
فكرتي انا
اتراثنا الاندمال الخرجه في ان يكون للباس
التقليدي يوم احتفال عالمي يكون مناسبه
للانفتاح ويراه ضيوف التظاهرات فرصه
للفرحه المشتركه
هو التراث هو لازم نحافظ عليه
رسميا عن طريقكم
يولي اليوم العالمي لباس التقليدي والهويه
الرساله اللي بغينا نبعتوها لخوتنا
والاشقاء التوانسه هو كل فرحه كي يفرحوها
كنقولوا لهم راه حنا معكم في الفرحه
ودائما ان شاء الله فرحين
ولكل منها حكايته تشق الخرجه المدينه
العتيقه ذلك الرمز التاريخيه واكبر سوقا
للصناعات التقليديه متجهه الى الشوارع
العصريه في حوار لمتناهن بين امس جميل لا
زال ياسر القلوب وحاضر ربما يريد ان
يستاثر بها
الافراح والالوان والبهجه انه اللباس
التقليدي التونسي في واحده من اكبر
احتفالاته يعانيد الدهر ويغالب الزمن الى
صباح العربيه احلام العبدلي تونس